men on average believe that the woman
that they're speaking to is more
attractive to them than she is and women
on average believe that the man that
she's speaking to is less attracted to
her than they are even just in that one
example of let's say an awkward
encounter in an office where the guy's
like well she keeps on lingering her
eyes at me and the woman's like oh isn't
he nice like she's like I got something
in my eye yeah exactly do you know what
I mean even in that situation you can
see one person sees one world and
another person sees another world it
very much is two different existences
that are going on this is one of the
reasons why you see like the popularity
of things like only fans the big big
money makers are women is because guys
think that these girls actually like
them oh you know I send her stuff and
she comments me you know she actually
kind of it's like back in the day when
you go with your body to the scripture
syndrome
[Music]